[Music]
when it comes to cuisine some like it
hot a quick way to satisfy a pecan
loving palate is with a splash or two of
hot sauce typically served with mexican
food such as nachos tacos and burritos
it can also spice up everyday fare such
as eggs potatoes and sandwiches
this american company has been producing
hot sauce also called a pepper sauce
since 1868.
its signature version is made from
tabasco peppers a type of chili pepper
the brand also comes in additional
varieties using habanero chipotle and
green jalapeno peppers the company has
pepper fields at its home base in
louisiana as well as in central and
south america using seeds harvested from
the louisiana crop the company president
uses his experienced eye to select the
best plants for seed extraction those
with even and early ripening juicy
peppers well-formed layered branches and
healthy damage-free leaves he marks his
selection with the string then pickers
harvest those peppers and send them to
the seed extractor
the peppers are hand-picked for sauce
production as well
to determine which ones are ripe enough
the pickers use what cajuns call a
petite baton rouge french for a little
red stick
if a pepper matches the color of the
stick they harvest it if not it stays on
the plant
it's labor intensive but ensures only
the perfect peppers go into the sauce
within hours of harvesting the factory
grinds the peppers and mixes them with
salt
this creates a mash which then goes into
oak whiskey barrels to ferment and age
wooden barrels breathe letting in just
enough air to spur natural yeast growth
the key to fermentation
but not too much air which would
discolor the mash and produce a metallic
flavor
after laying paper on top of the mash to
prevent surface discoloration
workers seal the barrels
then they spread a layer of salt over
the top
the barrels now go to the warehouse
where the mash ferments and ages for
three years
fermentation releases carbon dioxide gas
which forces liquid out through a vent
hole in the top of the barrel the salt
absorbs the liquid and hardens
[Music]
after the three-year fermentation and
aging period they break up the salt and
open the barrel
what was once pungent and acrid is now
aromatic with a mellow complex flavor
however it still needs significant
refining
so they pump it into large mixing tanks
add vinegar then churn for three to four
weeks
that's how long it takes for the vinegar
to break down the pepper solids into
smaller particles
during that process the vinegar also
takes on the color flavor and aroma of
the peppers
the sauce requires no cooking whatsoever
because the vinegar acts as a natural
preservative
the next step is a two-stage milling
process
the first mill extracts the pepper pulp
the second mill removes the seeds
the sauce is now finished
the quality control department analyzes
samples from every batch of sauce for
viscosity ph salt level and other
criteria
lab technicians also perform taste tests
for flavor clearing their palette in
between with crackers and cooling the
fiery heat with ice cream bars
once the batch gets the thumbs up it's
pumped to the bottling line
the company uses glass rather than
plastic because glass is a better
barrier against oxygen oxygen
penetration would adversely affect the
flavor and color of the sauce
the capping machine twists on a plastic
screw cap
then the bottles travel to the labeler
which adheres the main product label
slips on a decorative neckband and
applies a clear plastic seal over the
cap
hot off the production line and ready to
go
[Music]
you